OK, pop quiz.
What am I drawing?
I'm going to make three
predictions here.
Firstly.
You think at your house, you'd be
right?
Secondly, that that
just came pretty easily to you, it
was effortless.
And thirdly, you're thinking
that I'm not much of an artist
and you'd be right on all counts
there.
But how can we look at this set
of geometric shapes and think,
Oh, how?
If you live in a house, I bet it
looks nothing like this.
Well, that ability to perform
object identification that comes so
easily to us does not
come so easily to a computer,
but that is where we can apply
something called convolutional
neural networks
to the problem.
Now, a convolutional neural
network or a.
See, and and.
Is a area of deep learning
that specializes in pattern
recognition.
My name is Martin Keane, and
I work in the IBM garage
at IBM.
Now let's take a look
at how CNN works
at a high level.
Well, let's break it down.
CNN convolutional neural network
Well, let's start with the
artificial neural network part.
This is a standard network
that consists of multiple layers
that are interconnected,
and each layer receives
some input.
Transforms that input to something
else and passes an output
to the next layer, that's
how neural networks work and
see an end is a particular
part of the neural network or a
section of layers that say it's
these three layers here
and within these layers, we have
something called filters.
And it's the filters that perform
the pattern recognition
that CNN is so good
at.
So let's apply
this to our house example now.
If this house were an actual image,
it would be a series
of pixels, just like any image.
And if we zoom in on a particular
part of this house,
let's say we zoom in around here,
then we would get, well,
the window.
And what we're saying here is that a
window consists of some
perfectly straight lines.
Almost perfectly straight lines.
But, you know, a window doesn't need
to look like that window could
equally look like this, and we would
still say it was a window.
The cool thing about CNN is
that using filters.
CNN could also say that these
two objects represent the same
thing.
The way they do that, then, is
through the application of these
filters. So let's take a look at how
that works.
Now, a filter is basically
just a three by three block.
And within that block, we can
specify a pattern to look for.
So we could say, let's look
for.
Pattern like this, a right
angle in our
image.
So what we do is we take this filter
and it's a three by three block
here. We will analyze the equivalent
three by three block up here as
well.
So.
We'll look at first of all, these
first.
Group of three by three pixels,
and we will see how close
are they to the filter
shape?
And we'll get that numeric score,
then we will move across one, come
to the right and look at the next
three by three block of pixels and
score how close they are to the
filter shape.
And we will continue to slide over
or vote over all
of these pixel layers until
we have not every
three by three block.
Now, that's just for one filter.
But what that will give us is an
array of numbers that say how
closely and the image
matches filter,
but we can add more filters
so we could add another three by
three filter here.
And perhaps this one looks for a
shape like this.
And we could add a third filter
here, and perhaps this looks
for a different kind of right angle
shape.
If we take the numeric arrays
from all of these filters and
combine them together in a process
called pooling, then we have
a much better understanding
of what is contained within
this series of pixels.
Now that's just the first layer
of the CNN.
And as we go deeper into the
neural network, the filters
become more abstract all they can do
more.
So the second
layer of filters perhaps can perform
tasks like basic object
recognition.
So we can have filters here that
might be able to recognize
the presence of a window
or the presence of a door
or the presence
of a roof.
And as we go deeper into the sea
and into the next leg, well, maybe
these filters can perform even more
abstract tasks, like
being able to determine whether
we're looking at a house
or we're looking at an apartment
or whether we're looking at a
skyscraper.
So you can see the application
of these filters increases
as we go through the network and can
perform more and more tasks.
And that's a very high level
basic overview of what CNN
is. It has a ton of business
applications.
Think of OCR, for example,
for understanding handwritten
documents.
Think of visual recognition
and facial detection and visual
search.
Think of medical imagery and
looking at that and determining what
is being shown in an imaging scan.
And even think of the fact that
we can apply a CNN to perform
object identification for.
Body drawn houses, if
you have any questions, please drop
us a line below, and if you want to
see more videos like this in the
future, please like and subscribe.
Thanks for watching.